what role does personality play in being
a leader who earns trust
well the personality part how big your
personality is is si think about it in
terms of relationships like you go on a
date and someone has a big personality
that's very appealing I mean there's no
question about it but the more time you
spend with them you realize it's just
bluster were you going to date with
somebody who's a little bit quiet maybe
a little bit socially awkward but you
get along with them and you like them
and you spend more time with them and
you realize they're a really good person
so personality can be appealing at the
beginning but at the end of the day it's
about integrity Trust works the same way
whether we're talking about professional
relationships with with brands or with
each other so think about how we build
trust with each other it's very
difficult to build trust overnight
we can build trust quicker with some
people than others that definitely
happens but deep deep trust requires
time and the more time you get the
deeper the trust grows so so a
personality can can can be inviting but
it's not essential but you can we should
also sometimes be suspicious of people
who I mean like salespeople for example
or con artists not equating the two
notic waiting the two just saying that
what a confidence artist does is they
know the tricks to say things to us to
get us to trust them except it's not
real sales people good sales people it's
genuine and they really want to help us
but a smarmy salesperson sales person
who just wants to make the sale and
doesn't care about us they all say
anything they need to say to to to try
to engender trust but all of these
things fall apart in time and then the
second part of your question is does
self trust play a role so the difference
between I think I think confidence
always plays a role and there's there's
healthy ego and unhealthy ego healthy
ego is believing I'm good
unhealthy ego is believing I'm better
than you and I think all the best
leaders I've met they have they they
they definitely believe in themselves
but they don't believe that they're
they're better than other people they
think other people have great ideas
they think other people is smart they
think other people can teach them
they're just confident in what they know
and and many of them are very stubborn
about their visions they are there they
really want to build their visions and
I'm pretty stubborn about mine you know
that that creating a world that's
inspired safe and fulfilled I'm I'm
pretty stubborn about getting there and
everything from the people we hire to
the marketing decisions we make to the
the the this the the the the the
products we might might offer you know
every course that you're gonna see that
we're gonna offer in in the in the next
week where this gem start your why
always always always has to go towards
building that that vision because
because I'm stubborn
[Music]